Could you imagine if after everything, at the end of the day,
this was Pixie again? Could you imagine how that would be Could
you imagine? >> I just want my friend Steven sounding like
a again.
>> It's like he can't control it. There's this crazy thing
taking over the progressive part of the internet. This is a little
concept of consent.
>> You got at least two points, makes a line. Let's not
add more points to the line. You know what I'm saying? Like we
don't need more points in the line.
>> All right, I got I was sent some of this Lonerbox stuff.
We'll we'll cover it real quick. We have this tweet right here,
okay? Double life?
Lonerbox tries to silence ex-partner who is making accusations.
This is not true.
He did not silence this person. Come on, man. I already know
that's not true. Tries to silence ex-partner who is making accusations
of lying, cheating, and abuse by cutting out their dono, exposing
him from the VOD. Accusations include coercion, previously dating
a teen in his late 20s, and allegedly cheating without a condom.
So, this is the person who donated he got this donation through
his stream.
It's a Volvo donated 10 euro to say
Is that 10 pounds? No, it's 10 euro,
10 euro, 10 pounds? 10 pounds. It's 10
Really going to gloss over what you've done? How many people
you've hurt with your lying, cheating, and abuse?
This was made and I do think this was made like this person is
upset with them. They're fine with certain things being tied
back to him. Possible like there's probably an outside chance.
To me it seems like really elaborate to do if you were just with
him only. We'll go through this This was made and then very quickly
after that a Reddit account was found.
The Reddit account has posts in like subreddits about infidelity,
narcissistic spouses, life after narcissism, surviving infidelity.
These to me are done like a week ago, 2 weeks
These to me seem far more like just vent posts, like somebody's
venting. It doesn't seem like serious allegations. They're They're
basically saying exactly how they feel in their head. And you
always have to If somebody doesn't If it's not doing this publicly,
you always have to take into account a little bit that that if
they're doing it on like some new account they made, they at
this point probably didn't want to tie to anything. They just
wanted to vent to themselves, right? So, it like probably means
stuff was weird if they're a real partner. There's also the possibility
that some incredibly dedicated troll started posting this stuff
2 weeks ago in a way where they don't break character at all.
And then eventually they do the donation. Now, that theory is
sort of weakened at this point, okay?
We'll We'll read some of the posts after. That theory is sort
of weakened
on Lonerbox's actual YouTube VOD, the person who censored it,
incompetent that they are,
appears to have left it mostly like a large part of it in the
VOD still, okay? So, when you hit play, this is this pops up
and you can see that the donation is there. So, they both cut
it and left part of the donation in the in the VOD.
to me,
I think if this is just a random donation and you have no idea
what it's about, you don't live cut it from your Sorry, not live
cut, but you don't in place cut it from your YouTube VOD.
Right? Isn't their editor Stardust, infamous incompetent Stardust?
Yeah, it Could have been Lonerbox too, just trying to quickly
cut it out.
I just I feel like the edit If you just let it go, it probably
doesn't really turn into anything. Cutting it out sort of confirms
that it must be something to
Now, I'm not saying it confirms any of the allegations.
Um this could be somebody, you know, relationships end and and
people call each other abusive and then
you know, it's it's the end of a relationship. Can blow up sometimes.
You know what I mean You know what I'm saying? You know what
I'm saying?
But I think once you remove it, it sort of gives away the idea
that this is almost certainly somebody
I lean I lean towards 95 5 on like this is somebody related to
Lonerbox. Oh, I did see this though. It also There was also a
Twitter account and um Ela does her like survey question and
this this person this I think this is the only post they have.
They have like this and one other post. Oh, no. They did a response
on some Hasan tweet as well. Where would this go on the spectrum?
Partner finds out she was cheated on with multiple people and
condoms were never used. She would never have consented to with
that level of risk. Account was created around the time Lonerbox
took time off. I think that's relatively close to true. They've
got like two replies. They've got one reply here.
Oh, just to show that this is all real. >> what their cameras
did, I suppose. >> section of the VOD here. So, you do
get the cut there. The super chat begins popping up, almost entirely
visible. As we speak this This thing that this is just what their
cameras did, I suppose. Okay. As we speak this evening, it's
been I mean, I don't take a lot of this seriously until a person's
willing to like tie herself to the allegation in some way. Do
you know what I mean? I I see you guys like speculating on what
the all of this means. I don't really take it seriously
until you basically have somebody tying themselves to it. Like
it's
I would say I guess with the Twitter account, maybe those are
more solid like allegations, right? By deception, told a girl
I had a Bugatti and she was dumb enough to believe me. I mean,
that's technically There's something deceptive going on there.
I'd say that's definitely wrong, right? I know calling it is
is probably
But I mean, it could go It could go either way.
There There is something There's like a consent violation there.
It's just probably not on the level of right.
All right. With all that being said, there is more. There is
actually more here, all right? Consent violator gives his take
on consent. Destiny at the omniliberal out here seething because
people still believe consent matters. You literally can't make
this [__] up. One of the most annoying trends in
online progressive discourse recently is this concept of consent
just going everywhere. There's no way There's no way that he
said it that way. There's no way, right? Like if you're going
to have this conversation, why would you say it that way first?
Earth, we have conduction and Okay, I'm not going to dig into
drama because I love my everybody on this planet equally, okay?
I just want to make a quick meme comment. One of the most annoying
trends that have happened in like online progressive discourse
recently is this concept of like consent just going People try
to push this too to where if you don't have full information
about like a thing and it would have changed your mind about
having with somebody, it's like a non- This By the way,
hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Do you know the context I did that in? The context I did that
in was saying that it's borderline like e-rape if you are recording
without the other person's consent interactions.
That's That's where I said that. Where like that's bordering
on some form of like by deception, right? Because you're He should
just agree with that. Everybody should just agree with that.
What the [__]
Okay. All right. That's That's the idea.
Why would he
Why would he disagree with that? Yeah, obviously if you're going
to record and you don't let the other person know, that is a
major consent violation.
Okay, I'm not going to dig into drama because I love my everybody
on this planet equally, okay? I just want to make a quick meme
comment. >> again. One of the most annoying trends that
have happened in like online progressive discourse recently is
this concept of like cons- By the way, it's only discourse around
you because you're the only person who's done this kind of consent
violation.
Like it's It's just him.
Where Where's anything like this with
He's saying online progressive discourse. No, it's just people
talking about you and your crimes. That's like it. That's the
only place this conversation had to be had. Everybody else was
just like, "Oh, no, that's obviously true." sent just going People
try to push this too to where if you don't have full information
about like a thing and it would have changed your mind about
having with a non-consensual encounter or whatever. So, like
um if uh like if somebody like I'm trying to think of the most
ridiculous version of this. There's a thing He's going to try
to make something up. The The version I used and the version
Queen Man used was if you are recording audibly, auto audibly,
you know, visually, either one, without the other person's consent,
that is a consent violation. A massive consent violation.
Massive consent violation. You are a habitual consent violator
in that case. thing right now that's playing out in some other
community, but like >> like if somebody would have lied
about their job or if somebody would have lied about being racist
and you have with them and it's like, "Oh, well, you know, I
wouldn't have [__] this person if I would have known
that they were racist." But then people won't just say that.
"Oh, I wouldn't have slept with this dude if I thought he was
racist." They're like, "Oh, our encounter, that was a non-consensual.
I wouldn't have consented." Anytime they try to wheel out that
consent just the word consent. "I didn't consent consent to try
to like invoke like this idea." Um I like how now for when it
comes to Like I think at best, okay? >> At best we had
some conversation where like if you
There's like a whole rainbow. There's a whole spectrum of how
bad this gets. Like if you have AIDS, you could have
and you ex- you obviously deleteriously affect their life going
forward. If you have AIDS and you somebody without disclosing
it, right? They would never have with you if you told me you
have
Right? Obviously that's the worst case. There are like later
cases where it's like, "Ha, I said I I said I'd take you to breakfast
this mor- tomorrow morning and I didn't do that." And you never
would have had with me if I didn't take If I wasn't going to
take you to breakfast. Right? Like it's There's obviously a massive
spectrum there. That it was oh, the trans thing being tantamount
to rape. Yeah, sure, we can point that out for Destiny that he
said that if you had if you were having sex with a trans person
and but you didn't know they were trans, you thought they were,
you know, whatever they pass as, and they suddenly had a penis,
you know, you thought they had a penis, they suddenly have a
penis. That's tantamount to rape was Destiny's impression. But
you notice, it's very much like the Gaza thing. He invokes names
of people who bring these things up, right? And then he won't
actually say what the thing was that happened. What was the actual
comparison?
Just say the actual comparison. Don't go, "Oh, well, other people
do this absurd thing." and then totally make something up. That's
goofy. saying what trans is the worst thing in the universe and
your whole family lines should be murdered if anybody shoots
ever. Sorry, this is what I was pausing for.
Well, boy, did I pop in at the wrong time? Well, boy, did I pop
in Did I ever pop in at the wrong time?
Did I ever pop in at the wrong time here, guys?
Dude, I'm sorry. I just
you know, it is what it is, man. It is what it is. Hello. Who
this? >> Hey, there goes my friend Steven sounding like
a robot again.
>> It's like he can't control it. There's this crazy thing
taking over the progressive part of the internet. This is a little
concept of consent.
I didn't tell you that what? Consent? Consent? Right. Okay, man.
Dude, did you notice that like if it's if it's so bad the things
we're doing, the comparisons we're making, why can't you just
say the thing? It's the same thing as Gaza. I really hate what's
going on in Gaza. These people like to talk about consent. So,
just say the thing that happened. Just say, you know, the thing
we were calling you a consent violator for. But you don't want
to. I noticed that. You don't want to say it. You don't want
to say it. >> out, just say Just say, "I don't believe
that recording someone
without that consent
is a by deception. I don't think that's that big of a deal. Say
that on your live stream. That's saying. And also say I did it.
>> I mean, he basically
That's basically happened already, but whatever. I don't want
to I don't want to get into litigating the whole thing there,
but yeah, exactly. >> I mean like like like that. I mean
like like that. Yeah. Now, for when it comes to cheating, what
trans is the worst thing in the universe and your whole family
lines should be murdered if anybody shoots ever. But I like how
when people are cheating, it's not just like, "Oh, this person
cheated on me." It's like, "Not only did this person cheat on
me, but I was exposed to the risk of STDs, meaning I didn't consent
to sexual activity with him knowing that that extra risk." It's
like, "Oh my god, can't can't stop. Jesus Christ."
Well, like those are kind of the same thing, right, in this case?
So, I don't know if you watched the end of this clip, but he's
saying, "Oh, they're saying it's like rape by deception." cuz
or she I don't even think she said that. She didn't say that
at all as far as I could tell. Um she's saying, "I was exposed
to STDs." which was a problem for her, right? And if they knew
that was a problem for her, like if if let's say hypothetically
this is all real and Lonerbox did know that, it's like and I
would say even further if they had an agreement that he would
use protection with other women, then yeah, I would consider
that cheating suddenly. Right? I think that's the thing that
happens is she says it's cheating because she probably knew she
he was going to [__] other people, but that that
he [__] other people within without or sorry, outside
of the agreement, that would be the thing that's upsetting, I
think. Is she sure it's only Lonerbox?
I thought the allegation was more
Lonerbox is like cheating cheating. Just
Well, or maybe maybe that too. Yeah, she said like, "Oh, I had
a revelation that he was like seeing other people." Sure.
Seeing other people having unprotected sex. It sounds like she's
basically just upset that he's [__] other people,
It's not even like It's not even a by deception argument. It's
like a deception deception argument.
>> be like super
upset about it even if it's true. Hold on, let me pull the Aella
comment real
Cuz like basically outside of this
and by the way, Destiny, when Aella's explaining this to him,
what what part of this spectrum thing did Destiny not go, "Wow,
that's really interesting and cool and neat."? He should have
loved He should have loved consent conversations when it was
with somebody who was like Aella. He loved those conversations
suddenly. Right? And by the way, she's not even calling it anything
like this. She's saying she was deceived in some way. Having
sex with an unenthusiastic sex worker goes on here.
It's like the whole point is a conversation. Destiny used to
love
He just goes in some rant that's way closer to his situation.
He basically rants about his own situation.
And he uses Lonerbox as like the fodder for it. People talk about
consent. People They They just abuse this term.
Uh I said this earlier, okay? I still I'm still I still like
Lonerbox, but it's like you got at least two points, makes a
line. Let's not add more points to the line. You know what I'm
saying? We don't need more points in the line. We just don't.
You know, that's all. Just don't add more points, man. I want
more points. There is more. There is actually more here, all
right? So, there's 20 posts on Reddit. I didn't see this. So,
this is the first post. I didn't see this one when it was made
originally. Day 10, no Lonerbox stream. This is from Spider.
And somebody says, "Any updates since he ended his stream early
watching the Lorenz debate?" He just went to get some milk. He'll
be back anytime. And she says, "Hopefully not." They say, "Hopefully
not." Yikes. What the heck?
That's pretty mean. I also didn't notice
nobody had shown me that from the Reddit post. So, I mean, that
makes it pretty
So, now we've now we've eliminated the idea entirely that this
is somebody not related to Lonerbox
in one way or another. I don't think it's guaranteed that it's
a
but I'd say it's like 95/5,
maybe even 99/1 that it's a partner, former partner. Right? But
it is somebody who is intentionally doing this to Lonerbox. There
was some question when I first saw this of whether or not they
were actually referencing Lonerbox with a lot of the other comments.
But it's pretty clear. They made the account. They were focused
on Lonerbox. They believe they had a relationship with Lonerbox.
And
they made some more posts about it. So, we'll we'll read these
and I think the intention of the person is to make it seem like
these are about
You get this person on stream? Well, I That's the thing is I
don't know if I feel comfortable doing that. It feels like kind
of [__] up to go and try to get this person to come
on stream and like spill your guts. Um this person says, "Incredibly
boring and it took me far too long to find out that he's so completely
empty as a person that takes parts of other people's personalities
and adopts as his
This uh another thread. "Why do you narcissistic women Sorry,
narcissistic men cheat with every woman who Oh, do I have to
pull these up? I do narcissistic men cheat with every woman they
have been with, even if it's a good woman they've only been with
for a month."
And a response in this thread is, "Because they only feel something
with someone else is there and they need to feed their ego by
having power, having things they think they deserve because they
are grossly entitled. In this case, multiple relationships. They
are also constantly avoiding emptiness, shame, and self-hatred,
so multiple situations keep them distracted."
Damn. Okay, this is another thread. What is this one? Death by
a thousand cuts. "I'm divorcing my husband over infidelity. Prostitutes
and my best friend for years and only found out about the nature
of his behavior
So, she goes and says bec- Oh, sorry. "I'm in a similar situation
and I can say that not engaging is the only way. These people
are manipulative beyond belief and know exactly what they're
doing." I guess this is maybe asking for
This person's like trying to ask how do you deal with the person
trying to reach out to you, right?
Um oh, "Since I'm divorcing him over an objectively cruel thing
towards me, he is killing me with Darvo. This is
Is it a dude? I don't think so, but maybe. Okay, we're going
to keep going. We keep going. We keep going. Complaining? I don't
know. My husband and I are 25. We've had a super tough year with
our relationship, but had only slowly been making progress with
therapy the last couple days. I've been extremely extremely extremely
horny wanting physical touch from him. I'm I've asked him, flirted,
teased, gotten my toys out in front of him, and asked to play.
He keeps saying he's in the mood so and I'm so thrown off. Is
this reasonable? This is from the advice subreddit. Jesus. Why
are we here? Honestly, it sounds like you're pressuring him into
sex, which is the least attractive thing you can do. It is also
coercive. No means no, and you should respect that and back off.
Have a conversation about it like an adult instead. Oh, this
is not related to Lonerbox at all. What the [__]
This is like random advice.
I've been hoodwinked.
I've been hoodwinked. I'll try to keep to the narcissist subreddits,
okay?
Then we can keep it locked in. I've been hoodwinked.
All right. The part I'm struggling with most is not understanding
how he could have done it all. I can't imagine treating someone
I love like that. It just doesn't make sense.
My friend is not letting me break with
Stop thinking about the impact on him and start thinking about
why he picked you out as a teenager instead. Man's a predator
and an abuser. Get out of
Advice. This There's that By the way, this is the most Reddit
behavior I've ever seen in my entire life. Half the comments
giving advice to other people. Why are you doing that? You don't
get to vent about how your life's blowing up and go to the advice
subreddit and start giving advice to other people at the same
time. What the [__] are you doing? Yeah, this guy
totally fooled me for a long time, and I was I was totally hoodwinked.
How do I deal with my relationship? Well, sweetheart, break up
with him immediately. That's what you do. It's like, "What? Why?
Why would you do Get out. Break up with him. I think if you're
questioning this behavior, then you already know the answer.
Here's a good one. Rewriting history, meaning an ex-spouse. My
My ex-
ex-spouse always rewrites history.
Internet has mind poisoned me. "I've moved on so much, but the
constant rewriting of history and lack of justice in the situation
is so hard for me to accept. He sent me a huge text saying he
held the marriage together when I didn't do anything. He cheated
and abused me and the kids and was never around. I need advice
on how to accept the constant rewrites. Do I just ignore it?
The rewriting, the gaslighting, the cherry-picking, the long
silences and distractions when they can't answer simple direct
questions. It's all crazy-making. It's deliberate and abusive
behavior, and it probably won't stop. They will just keep doubling
down. Why is a big age gap, 13 years, such a
This could be related to later, but we'll we'll keep looking.
Okay, there's I know there's a there's
con- there's another concept coming up that we'll take a look
at, okay? Okay, so at the beginning they're being far more By
the way, this is mostly not about Lonerbox in this case. Like,
right? They're They're doing advice posts and [__]
like that.
They're not really going that hard at that in on this specific
person.
Life after narcissism. Feeling bad about something my narc said.
Not this one, this one.
Feeling bad about something my narc said before no contact.
They want you to feel as bad as possible. They want the upper
hand to feel superior in every situation, and then they say stuff
like this so you feel low about yourself that you beg them to
go not to go no contact. They're vile people who need to have
control over you. They have done nothing to deserve it, and you
are now free to live life and go on your own terms without a
person who emotionally abuses you to the point you feel worthless.
It's a gift. So, again, little bits of shade so far, not really
a lot of talking about their specific situation yet, okay? I
It was a terrible relationship from hell, my first serious relationship,
but he and me both know it that it didn't last only the that
3 months, but way longer. Told me we were only together 3 months,
and good times between us only lasted 1 week.
They rewrite history to suit whichever narrative best enables
them to stay in control of you and whatever you are feeling.
You know what happened. You know the truth. Whatever he said
doesn't change anything.
Okay. Well, it's mostly responding Well, hold on, but some of
them like these are he's clearly Sorry, they are clearly saying
something here, right? That this is them talking about one specific
person the whole time. Like, they're they're saying they they
as in mine and
Right? So, they're they're trying to add something in here. Okay,
hold on.
Stop apologizing for your reaction to their disrespect. Listen
closely to these words. This is exactly what I what I feel every
single time.
So much of this. He's probably already going through our messages
ready to paint me as an the unhinged crazy ex. I don't give a
[__] I understand exactly what was happening now.
I said the craziest thought. I said the craziest thought in the
world, but I can't say it.
But could you imagine if after everything at the end of the day
this was Pixie again? Could you imagine how that would be Could
you imagine if this was on a pseudonym?
That'd be crazy, right? I It's not. It's not. It's not. It's
not. I just thought in my head I was like, "Oh my god,
Cuz that's the only person I know who has had a relationship
with Lonerbox at And as far as I know they got along, so you
know, you know, it is what it is.
I In my head I'm like, "Wait, wouldn't that That would be insane."
Okay. I've had the same thoughts that this person I loved made
me feel like I've lost a part of my own humanity. I'm working
through those feelings in therapy. I know I've been pushed over
any limit that is normal for uh for a person to take, and that
helps me process my own actions and feelings. This is Going Hollow
is the name Narcissistic Spouses.
I'm at the very um at a very early stage in processing what this
person did and the trauma he has caused. In all honesty, I'm
probably still in shock, and I'd say journaling always helps
and finding a good therapist if that is accessible to you. Why
did I allow her to make me feel things like
uh why did I allow her to make me feel things like things were
my fault? She abused me for 3 years, blah blah blah blah blah.
Don't care. Because they are experts at making you feel like
you are doing something wrong. They deliberately try They're
deliberately trying to control you. They're deliberately trying
They're deliberately try to control you. That's what she meant.
Confuse you and make you feel worthless. Once you are out of
that fog, things start to become clearer.
I'm still begging while he feels nothing. Now, I'm sitting alone
in my room waiting for a single call from him. I've been texting
and begging him to talk to me, and he just says he's busy and
shows no empathy at all. I can't even Uh let's see. He does it
on purpose. He's emotionally abusive, and the best thing you
can do is get some space and some support to make a plan and
make to make a plan to leave him.
Bringing the r/advice and r/relationshipadvice
stuff into Narcissistic
Spouses. Is that the one we're in now? I think it's Narcissistic
Wow. Okay.
Boyfriend lied to me multiple times. I don't know what to do.
No, don't care. Advice subreddit Narcissistic Spouses. Journaling
has saved me. If I hadn't done that done it, I would've been
gaslit to death by now. Our ex-spouse got worse after starting
therapy. Yep, after starting therapy he started a narrative that
I was stalking and harassing him and that he was scared of me.
I had hoped he was going to address his abusive behavior in therapy,
but no, he set about trying to make me the abuser instead. It's
horrible because I can very much deal with people talking [__]
about me, even him, but I'm really struggling with how he mistreated
me and the things he did while we were together. The lasting
effect of it all The lasting effect all of it is going to have
on me, etc. And to add on top of that his Sorry, and to add on
top of that, his total aversion to addressing any of those issues.
I feel like that broke something inside of me. Now, that one
would be about whoever she's talking about. Presumably
Which is kind of weird. Control F leave him. I won't do that
to her. Hold on, leave him.
Only two. Only two. Only two. Only two. Okay, it's not that bad.
Not that bad.
Started a narrative that I was stalking and harassing him. Now,
the thing is this person is from Scotland, so you do wonder if
there's somebody that Loner would know in real life, right? It
seems likely that they would know him in real life to me. It
seems pretty likely. Like, if this person is
if Pixie and Loner break up
Uh well, Loner's poly. They wouldn't have to break up.
Uh Do they know they're projecting? This might seem like a dumb
question, but do abusers know they're projecting to hide their
own lies, or do they really truly believe their their victim
is as as vile as they say they are?
I think they know. I've been accused of doing things that I didn't
do, but that he did to me. Of hurting him in the ways he hurt
me. Of plotting against him for the whole time we were together.
It's obvious he was doing this about me. Of mistreating the ways
he mistreated me.
Some of it I noticed during the relationship and would argue
about. Some of it I ignored and put down to chronic paranoia.
But now that we are over, it's reached a whole new level projection,
and it's genuinely quite scary. I think he knows and he doesn't
care. He will do anything to avoid accountability. He'll do anything
to play down play down or outright dismiss what he's done, or
just wants to make me the villain.
Geez. Um hmm.
Man, I don't know how to look at this. It's really hard to get
a read exactly. Like, this person seems a tad bit dramatic, but
like I also don't want to totally I I can't like discount them
without knowing anything more, right?
Like, I'm guessing some bad stuff
Like, I'm guessing I feel like you don't get posts about this
if if you've done nothing wrong. But that's I mean, maybe that's
a little too far.
Dude, I'm trying to I'm trying to get like a my bearings as I
read through this, and it's Oh, we'll see. I don't know what
to do anymore. Relationships. A 27-year-old man picking out a
19-year-old woman for a relationship is predatory. He targeted
you as a teenager so he could abuse you, and he knew you'd feel
unable to stand up for yourself or leave. This is not about Lonerbox,
although I think there's a tweet that's
We'll see. Not tweet, read a post. Uh Surviving Infidelity. Husband
was living a double life. It's around 2 weeks since I found out
my ex had a double life. We split up in December.
And I feel like all life has lost all color. I don't feel like
any of it is real. I'm seeing the coded messaging. But also feel
sick thinking about any memory of us. I can't concentrate on
anything. I do have some support, but it's very much one day
at a time thing. We will get through this, ex. So, they gave
up Or sorry, they they broke up in December.
That's like a long time. That's a long time to have this going
on for, no? Like, that We're now 3 months later.
4 months later. That's
That's a lot, okay?
Surviving Infidelity. They are discussed They are cowards, disgusting,
lying, cheating, manipulative cowards. Their decisions will catch
up with them at some point.
The feelings of this person who loves me betrayed me in such
an awful way. How could they he do that? In this thing uh is
is the thing, sorry, I'm currently or I'm currently struggling
with. I want to feel anger, and I'm sure I will at some point,
but right now I feel like I want to understand the why when there's
nothing more to really under- Nothing There's really nothing
more to understand than he was a a habitual liar and a cheat.
That he mistreated me repeatedly. Those are facts.
Those are the facts. Nothing else really matters. None of the
good times, the great connection you had makes a difference.
You deserve better.
I need the context on this one. Give me a second. Is it bad that
I feel bad for my ex even though he put me through
Same. The way I see it, it reflects on you, and it reflects on
him in the end, who both of you are as human beings. Your heart
is big enough to try to understand and figure out the motives
behind such harmful and despicable behavior, to come from a place
of empathy, yet he is the one who has carried out that behavior
and probably gives no [__] about the damage he's
done, and won't make any real effort to address it, any of it.
You're just a decent caring human, and you deserve better while
he deserves to lose you.
that's a lot That's a lot to read in. Let's see the post that
she got such a good read on.
I feel like it's such a shame
he ruined what we had. I truly believed in him and supported
him through and through. He didn't have anyone else by his side.
That's why I felt so protective of him and let him get away with
so much. He manipulated, used, cheated, and abused and cheated
on me. Why can't I let go of the pity and disappointment I feel
towards him? Damn. Damn. Damn.
That's a lot of a read, but okay. Thought relationship was great,
he was
Damn. This dude, there's a lot of posts. I We're getting closer
to the end though We're getting a lot closer to the end. Hold
on.
It's uh
Yeah, we got like 10 posts left, all right? We'll We'll go through
all of of Why not?
Oh yeah, I certainly did not see that coming. I'm not going to
go in on like
deeper here, but I Listen, two points make a line. So, let's
not put anything else in this trend line, okay?
Two points make a line. Let's not put more things on the line,
right?
And in this case, it's more like, you know, don't put more points
on the line. I'm just I'm begging. Let's not put more points
on the line, okay?
We don't we need a scatter plot. You can already tell it's going
the wrong direction. We don't need a scatter plot. We just want
to want to reverse the trend.
Want to reverse the trend.
Hey, notice red flags reverse the trend. I believe in you.
Dude, I should have a drink for this. This is depressing to read,
to be honest with you. Jeez, very long. That relationship was
great. He was cheating the whole time. 2
He says, "I felt sick reading this because I'm going through
the same thing. Found out a couple weeks ago my ex was living
a whole double life while we were in a relationship. I know it
feels like you want comfort and he's the person to provide that,
but it's only going to be harder for you in the long run if you
stay close to him. This man betrayed you in one of the worst
ways possible. You're in a vulnerable position and he's continued
to manipulate you. Please find support and have some space from
him to be able to see things clearly."
Wow, I I've not seen her say how long the relationship was.
My ex-fiancé admitted to pulling away.
Think I'm glad I found Dude, I'm going to be so happy when I
don't have to worry about setting him off anymore before we so
before we sort everything out. See him off before we sort everything
out, okay? I think I'm glad I found out, but the betrayal was
so huge and so sickening that I feel unable to process it. On
one hand, it's good to know that my gut feeling was right, but
I'm also overwhelmed with every emotion under the sun at what
is coming out about this man I thought I knew and
It's disturbing. Oh god. Uh-oh.
You know what that says to me? Uh I I have a prediction.
Oh boy, I have a prediction. I must announce a prediction. This
means she's talking to another person. That's
Not Lonerbox. If this is all real,
she's talking to somebody else.
That's she's talking to somebody else.
That's not good. That's not good at all. Uh-oh.
It's not great, man. It's not great. It's not great. It's not
ideal, okay?
Uh-oh. [snorts] So, here we go. How to make a cheater confess,
surviving infidelity. So, oh, this person's like my long-distance
relationship is cheating. I How do I get them to confess? What
you do is leave.
Uh hold on, I'll actually read it here. What you do is leave.
For them to admit what they did would mean they care about your
needs in this moment and want to help you heal. It would mean
they have to be fully honest and face themselves, which would
show some kind of growth and compassion in them whether you left
them or whether you left them or not. But most of them are just
as bad just bad people who want to hurt again and again and again.
They're like the human equivalent of Israel. Okay, I shouldn't
make everything about that. They don't ever want to be accountable
for their actions. They don't care.
Damn. This one was
Pity for the narcissist.
Did I Should a narcissist ever be pitied? Did he own what he
did to you? Did he hold himself accountable in any way? Did he
have empathy for you at any point? If no, then there's your answer.
These people don't give a [__] about anyone but themselves.
So, why should you care about what happens to them?
Yaha. Okay. Uh pity for a narcissist. Same thread, different
post.
That's the thing. Despite all the [__] the one positive
ray is that he did have empathy when I was at my lowest. He tried
to help me. He listened when I needed to talk. All the times
he was just horrible, but he was there for me at my lowest and
I feel obligated to return the same. They do whatever it takes
for them to get what they want. It's not genuine empathy. If
it had been genuine, it would have kept it would have been ongoing.
Damn. Got cheated on and lied to for months. How do you
How do you actually move on?
Miss him, I just want my peace back. How do you stop thinking
about it all the time? What actually helped you get let go mentally?
So, these people just asking for help with like intrusive thoughts
and spiraling on stuff.
I found out a few weeks ago that my ex
Dude, I It's kind of rough that this this this right here is
like, I need to stop thinking about this.
This person broke up with Lonerbox apparently 3 months before
this and she's posting advice on how to stop thinking about it
and stop letting it dominate your life.
Just saying.
Just saying. I'm just say I'm just
I'm just I'm just saying that like probably
you haven't figured it out and so probably you don't have a lot
to share.
Oh, hold on. Wait.
I think she's saying that. Oh, maybe I Maybe I blew her up too
quickly.
I found out a few weeks ago that my ex had a whole double life
and put multiple women at risk via unprotected sex. I feel like
my whole world has been turned upside down and cannot stop the
thoughts. So, I just want to let you know you're not alone.
Oh, so yeah, she's actually not giving advice here. Okay, you
know what? That's my bad. I jumped up I jumped down her throat
a little too quickly. I jumped down her throat a little too quickly,
okay?
My bad. My bad. But this is leading us more again to what the
actual allegation here is is that apparently
it doesn't It seems like she's talking to like about infidelity.
But put multiple women at risk via unprotected sex. It seems
more like, you know, this goes with the Twitter comment
I didn't know that he wasn't using a condom with other people,
right? Like having
like bareback sex with somebody you're a contin- continuous monogamous
partner with is super different than having bareback sex with
like a bunch of different partners, right? Like it Like that
is something in and of itself that I could totally get why somebody
would be upset about that. That makes total sense to me, right?
So, it depends on what the arrangement was. I don't know what
the arrangement was. The arrangement was, we're poly, I [__]
whoever I want and we don't really talk about it and he the person's
having sex with a condom with you. If you don't make sure that
the agreement is you If you have other partners, you have condom
with them. If you don't make sure of that, then I would assume
whatever they're doing with you, they would be doing with the
other partners, right?
Like the assumption would be that they're they're going to do
whatever you're they're doing with you with everybody else unless
you actually make it a part of the agreement otherwise. It's
a Your lawyer, I advise you not to use the term bareback.
I'm trying to make Lonerbox seem gay, okay? The nail polish wasn't
enough.
Okay, is it working?
Is it working? They're both doing poly. Okay. All right.
All right. All right. All right. All
Keep going. Okay, what's the worst smear you've heard your next
shares? Oh, and earlier was a narcissist. Got it. Oh, this is
not good. What's the worst smear you've heard your next shares
with
Damn. Apparently there's something that's been getting shared
about her. He's been telling people I'm coercive. Projection.
That he's scared of me and has been our whole relationship. He
pursued me and made every effort to keep me in his in his life.
That I've threatened him multiple times and since I found out
the extent of what he's done, he's trying to silence me by saying
I'm stalking and harassing him. All I want is for him to be accountable,
to admit what he's done.
Oh, I don't know. I'm not going to jump entirely in the other
direction yet.
Cuz I understand this person feels like someone's being silenced
about something terrible that was done to them that they feel
terrible about. But she is the one who, you know, has made these
accounts and then tied them to Lonerbox's stream,
I will say that has happened. So, the the idea that you're trying
to put this into his public sphere life as well is a thing. It's
possible he deserves that.
If there was If there was If this was all true, what she's saying
is true that like there was a agreement that was violated where
he was supposed to protect her health by using condoms with other
people, he wasn't doing that and that he's kind of being like
hot and cold and intentionally sort of manipulating and and making
it seem like he really cares and then going totally cold and
saying like you're actually evil and you're trying to hurt him.
If that's all happening,
then okay, like maybe there's some comeuppance deserved and maybe
this isn't that bad. But right now, I don't I don't see that.
I can't. I Again, it's just need more information basically.
Need a preview. Well, I Dude, there's no more information.
What am I supposed to do?
Dude, these people This person has a way rougher life. Heard
him covertly tell a friend that our problems were due to me being
jealous of him. I don't mean to sound like an [__]
but I am like 10 times more successful than him in in just about
every aspect. I am very fit. He's 400 lbs. I am successful at
my job and he can't keep one. I complete I complete what I start
and he can't commit to anything. I am emotionally mature and
he, well, he is NPD, so I don't think I even need to go there.
So, yeah, that one really pissed me off.
That Oh, Z Z. Yeah, I've got I've got that clip here. Yeah, maybe
we sprinkle that in in the
I wonder Well, I haven't I haven't gotten everything yet. That's
the only problem. I haven't gotten everything yet. So, I don't
know all the information. So, I'll I'll wait and keep reading
and then we have There's like a Destiny clip that got thrown
out. I don't know if anybody else has looked at this. I'm sure
Queenman looked at it, too. I can't imagine Queenman's super
far off of where I am. I can't imagine.
What's the most confusing behavior you experienced in a relationship
that still doesn't fully make sense? Him putting so much effort
into getting me back in his life when I had so many doubts. He's
now rewriting all of it like I forced him into a relationship.
He was seeing someone else the whole time. It doesn't make sense
that he did any of what he put me through. He could have just
had a relationship with the other person and left me the [__]
alone instead of mistreating me for a year. Oh, there's the year
part. Damn.
I have a bonus Loner comment on Noah Samson. I saw Somebody linked
me the Noah Samson thing and he unfortunately he did like the
Nicholas De Oreo comment, which was kind of
on Noah Samson and the funny thing is is
hold on, maybe you linked it. Let me see. Let me see the clip
you linked first cuz I I saw this earlier somebody linked it.
Bro, I really I really hope Noah wasn't two girls at once. Oh,
no.
Can I just not be that?
He says he says that jokingly obviously. >> this kind of
[__]
The thing about it though is that if it is that then I'm sorry,
these guys
these guys will actually try to ruin you over like that. So,
why not? Now, unless I'm missing my mark on that one that's him
essentially saying and maybe I'm misunderstanding. It's possible.
I not I've listened to that much, okay? But I I think that was
essentially
okay?
Nicholas Ybarra, well, listen, I hope they're not blowing him
up over like something tiny like two girls at once. But also,
he tried to ruin other people over this. So, I don't even feel
sympathy for him. I hope it's not that. I hope it's not that
defense I'm hearing there.
Cuz you'll notice I was like, "Oh, I I bet you people would want
to like reach out to this person." I thought about it, right?
Like oh, I bet people would want me to reach out to this person
and like have her on stream and see what she's going to say.
But then I'm like, "Nah, it just seems like it's very weak to
begin with and I feel like, you know, based on the allegations,
I don't know if it's appropriate to go and like do a whole song
and dance." I didn't go, "Oh, well, these guys laughed when it
happened to Noah Samson, so it's okay to do it to Luna Box."
I went, "No, I kind of didn't like what they did it to Noah Samson.
Feels kind of inappropriate to do it to Luna Box, right?" To
try to go get this person on and like drag them through the mud
as much as possible and like try to farm as much as possible.
It feels like kind of shitty.
And that's how that's how I feel. I'm not trying to measure them
against their
I think Ethan Klein's a terrible person. I think Nicholas Ybarra's
well, terrible? Yeah, in some ways like a terrible person.
I don't want to I don't want to match them. Why would I want
to match them? The whole point is trying to be better than that.
The Tom X stuff was frankly
Yeah, unfortunately the Tom X stuff here's the thing. Sometimes
things come about in such a way that something is obviously horribly
morally up and hilarious at the same time, okay? And that's that's
unfortunate. All right, that's unfortunate. Yeah, this was the
last one we read. There's one more comment, okay? Ignore the
early signs because they seem too small to matter.
Uh the one I ignored was him talking about a teenager when he
had a relationship with or sorry, he had a relationship with
when he was in his late 20s. I told him I thought it was hugely
problematic, but he called her abusive, crazy, BPD, etc. Made
himself out to be a victim. He was a lot of green flags at the
start. I didn't want to believe he was bad. Like a little bit.
Like to be honest, as I've read this, it almost feels like it
could just be like a setup in the other direction.
Like, "Hey, I think a bunch of people are like crazy about Luna
Box and so if we write some story like this and we make it like
really perfect." Like it's all It's honestly It's honest to honest
to God, it's like throwing up so many red flags is like the
as like the posts. I don't know. It's hard to say. Oh, so she
already talked about like a 27-year-old and a
If this person was like a teenager that was younger
she would say that. The reason she says teenager cuz that's the
that's the worst thing she can say about it without being like
more specific.
She wants to say the worst thing she can, but she doesn't want
to get more specific
because but if in this case, it would be worse if if this person
were below 18. It would be worse if she got more specific. If
she could get more specific in that direction
she would. She is saying the worst thing she can because that's
how she sees Luna Box.
If you're fabricating a story, why would you set the date as
4 months in the
Fabricating a story. I don't know.
Wait, if you're fabricating a story, why would you say it is
4 months in the past? Oh, yeah, I don't know. Yeah, maybe not.
It just Sorry, it just feels like to me
like this is clearly the
Is this not also the story of how Destiny met his ex-wife and
then the same things that he said about his
>> Like how much overlap can you get before you're like,
"This seems too good to be true. This seems like
you know what I mean? Like this seems like way too much to even
be true at this point.
I just can't see how this could possibly be true. Yeah, yeah,
like it seems fabricated in the other direction almost. It just
seems like, "Oh, so many things that people who dislike Luna
Box would think are funny and would put
But it like I I'm saying that's like 1%. The other one's like
1%. 98% chance it's just like a person who's upset and feels
I'm not taking it like very seriously to be honest with you.
Like it's it's a serious situation, but I'm not I'm not looking
at it and
oh, like this is all guaranteed true. You got here just in time.
I think I'm going to watch uh I'm going to watch Spider Emery.
You down for that? Spider Emery?
I think Kathy's in there too or something, isn't he? That should
be That should be crazy, no? >> Jesus Christ. Isn't that
crazy?
Come on, man. What else we got for Hold hold on. Wait, Tequila
Sunset, you got a bunch of content? Other people got other kinds
of
Let's see. I'm going to pull it up. We'll do
We'll try to We'll try to listen for a little bit, okay? We'll
try to get a little bit little listen. >> Crazy you got
nothing better to do. That's just crazy, bro. I've got lots of
stuff better to do, but it's funny Hold on, you have to understand
that I have you here and you can say a whole bunch of like crazy
that I'm not going to say. Bro, you guys I don't know why you
got Why you guys got to hate on Spider? I like Spider content.
You guys just don't like Spider content. That's not my problem.
That's your problem.
I [__] I love watching Spider talk. I love watching
Spider go hard on people, okay? What are you What are you even
Luna Box? It's not amazing in the same way it's amazing the first
time you see like a black person doing the fent lane, you know?
It's like
Oh, yeah, they they do that.
And you move on.
I feel like you're being really weirdly racist for no reason
to this guy. He's not even Is he even black? We need to see how
black he is, okay?
>> Come over here. He's black or Hispanic or what's going
on with that guy? There's some There's something. Speaking of
all of these issues and especially Destiny's behavior in real
life and speaking about these issues. Anyway. Okay. Can we talk
about Luna Box about the recent allegations? >> I know
we haven't. I want to I mean we haven't I mean I don't care.
Hey Spider, what do you think?
I need more [clears throat] evidence. I So, like I need more
like Turkey Tom type of evidence. Not just like word of mouth.
I need like more screenshots, messages, you know what I'm saying?
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Obviously, no one is saying this is 100%. >> Yeah,
okay. I'll say this. Did you say he needs more Turkey Tom type
of evidence? Is that Is that what I just
Did he say he needs more Turkey Tom type evidence? Yeah. What?
Wait. So, allegation, man. I need some Turkey Tom type [__]
Wait. What? What What's your problem, dude? What's your problem?
Spider's the next IShowSpeed and you're not hopping on the train.
It's [__] up. I'll take this. I'll put this in my
back pocket. Okay? I'm not I don't believe this overall based
on this the less this like really barely any evidence. It's just
like hearsay like word of mouth. Oh.
Wait. I feel like I should get your position on this on this
stuff, Queen Man. The way I'm seeing it is like I think this
person probably posted all the stuff on Reddit not intending
for any of it to be examined in any way and then they made the
donation that ties all these things together. And probably when
they wrote the stuff, they didn't mean for it to be examined.
I wouldn't I wouldn't take any of those allegations as like 100%
like even the allegations they would make if you asked them about
it knowing who they are. You know what I mean? It seemed like
they were more venting.
And I do think they want to make some kind of allegation and
I do think they're tied to Luna Box based on the edit in the
VOD, but I don't think like
I don't think those necessarily like
stories even on Reddit are all 100% true. What do you think?
I I mean sure, could be that way.
You just got to know the I mean, yeah, sure. I'm saying basically
I probably have like 80 90% uncertainty, but like in the direction
I'm leading I I feel like I'm pretty sure this person knows Luna
Box. What do you think?
Yeah, I think they know Luna Box. Based on the edit. >> why
edit the VOD, right? Yeah.
You laugh at how poorly edited the VOD I did.
I think I need to masturbate on it. It might even be worse than
that. Might even be an Indian woman.
>> Like really barely any evidence. It's just like hearsay
like word of mouth. Like what the who the [__] Who
the [__] base evidence on word of mouth?
If the person Okay, we're not saying that you should believe
this 100%, no. But don't you have a little Okay, let's ask this.
What kind of evidence will this person Volvo or whatever they
name
present that will convince you they are telling the truth? I
need some like Turkey Tom evidence or something like screenshot
messages. Can you be more specific?
probably like What if everything here is the truth beyond like
oh, he was super abusive and lied to me about something. Like
just the
the having sex with other people with
I do think that like a lot of this adds up to basically
I don't know. Like you're not canceling this guy probably, right?
It's just like a kind of piece of [__]
Kind of a loser.
I don't know. I'm a big fan of just like if you lie to people
provably in any way, you should be [__] Like if you
just regularly lie.
I don't know. Doesn't seem like that. Lots Lots of people don't
like that. I heard Destiny was very upset about that. Destiny
tried to hyperbolize like oh people here people here like cheating
and they think you deserve to like die. It's like no, just like
lying to somebody that you're supposed to care about is bad obviously.
Not that complicated.
Probably like
I don't know because like videos is kind I don't know no okay
fine. A video is maybe or like or her taking a screenshot like
screenshotting him crashing out or something. You know. Okay
and if she presented this evidence
will you change your mind on Lana Box?
Nothing will change. Yeah but it's like damn any evidence?
Yeah. Yeah what? On the on the same allegations. Nothing new
just the same allegation that he's he's a serial cheater. >> oh
oh oh oh oh oh like the whole minor teenager
I don't know if it's a minor or not. She said teenager so we
can't rule it out. Oh I think I'll say this. He's a minor?
No no no she said no she says a teenager but that can mean like
18 or 19. >> could be 18 or 19. Well and that can be problematic
in and of itself and Yeah I think realistically
This person wants to say the worst things they can about Lana
Box. So if they could say 16 or 17 without being out out an outright
liar they would say >> Yeah for real that's like what my
immediate read on it was like okay you would say
you know first of all Lana Box would not describe his whatever
I simply could do not believe that Lana Box would describe his
16 year old girlfriend as abusive and BPD. I do not believe that
he thinks there's a single woman in the world that would buy
that if he said in his late 20s my 16 year old girlfriend is
really abusive and BPD is really hard to deal with. I I don't
think he's that stupid. I don't think he's that insane no matter
what.
So that's absurd anyway. I don't think he is. I do think somebody
could be convinced of that but yeah I I don't think he would
do that. Like him
Sure okay some people could be convinced of it but broadly
that's going to not going to fly. That's going to be a very difficult
sell.
It's going to be very very difficult
And then yeah she she she would say um Cuz it was sold right?
This person did believe him when he said that right? I told him
I thought it was hugely problematic but he called her abusive
crazy BPD etc. made himself out to be the victim. He was a lot
of green flags at the start. I didn't want to believe he was
bad.
As in I totally bought that when he told me that.
I'm lucky.
I mean depends on what you mean by totally
As in you bought it for the reason upon re-examining
put put things to the side in that in their mind and just sort
of like oh yeah I guess so. Yeah that's And then Probably you.
I think you know early in a relationship anybody can be convinced
of that. >> everything they've said.
Yeah. Yeah I just feel like it's a red flag immediately. Like
she's probably
Okay sure put it to the side. Like ignored it pretended it didn't
exist. To me that's like it working but sure. I mean it's it's
it's it working but that's all right. I mean when you say you
bought it I feel like that it seemed like you were saying like
you know you believe it. But no I mean Yeah sure.
People will
accept explanations for things they don't necessarily fully believe.
Sure. Not a minor though. I think that's probably more problematic
of him just being a cuz based off her accusations is is probably
just him being a [__] boyfriend right? Am I tripping
am I crazy or what? Well
It would down to the conversation of Really it's like be boyfriend
but then it would be if he's cheating
and he's not using condoms if that is the case then
there's a conversation on the spectrum that people are having
where I wouldn't call them a I don't think people should just
flow throw throw that out for cheaters in
Hold on.
This may be
the one time where I'm going to take Aella seriously in my entire
life. Hold
If I look at this if I look at this how
where would you actually call somebody a here is the question.
Cuz that's the whole point of the question right? Is where where
do you actually call somebody a
I can't think of why. But it is like worthy of like critical
condemnation to a degree because you are
the potential even if inadvertently if somebody else like what
one of the people that you were cheating on like that that person
that that they don't know what partner they're sleeping with.
expand on the she's a [__] boyfriend
or what.
No I'll say cheater is not being a [__] boyfriend.
No no. It's like it's a character like you can't judge a person
on the fact that they are not only cheated once they have a history
of
12 is way worse.
Okay. Well Thailand's a truly horrific place then. Remember Coach
Katie said the same thing. And that was years ago. She said
It'd be a combination on how you treat women or whatever and
uh Yeah yeah people in general. I'm I'm confused on your tweet.
This I'm just want your
like what collision is. So I'm confused on the whole allegedly
cheating without a condom. So can I ask like I'll put it like
can I read it? I'll read it. Yeah you go ahead. A double life
Box Lunch. Okay I was a little bit more straightforward in saying
as if this is a fact of the matter. I'll be probably very charitable
maybe this is not the
I'll state this for the record I don't know this for certain
but See this is why we cover spider content on the
Who comes in and goes spider let's Oh. See people are excited
about the spider content. I don't know what to tell you Queenman.
You were just wrong about spider okay? This guy's a This guy's
an up and comer. This is my gauge this is what I believe actually
happened here. Tries to silence ex-partner who is making accusations
of lying cheating and abuse by cutting out their donor exposing
him from the vod. The accusations include coercion previously
dating a teen in his I don't know how this person could stand
on this.
I I actually this is This is like a lot. This is like total clickbait
obviously. Yeah. 20s and allegedly cheating without a condom.
That's um that was the tweet.
>> Can you can you explain I just meant um hold on.
As a silence ex-partner I think that's absurd the silence part
just cuz he's cut the don- he's cut the dono. previously dating
a teen in his late 20s and allegedly cheating without a condom.
That's um that was the tweet.
>> Can you can you explain
cheating without I'm I'm confused on the cheating without a condom.
So like did he cheat on did he cheat on her
If you're having unprotected sex with other people and your partner
is not aware of that the partner would probably
would not consent if they knew you were having unprotected sex
with other people. First of all they don't know that you're cheating
that's the first thing. That's a violation in and of itself but
if you're having unprotected
those she that partner doesn't know if you could be trusted that
like you with their the third line of being able to make sure
that they didn't have any STDs or anything like that. So
they wouldn't consent to that having knowing that you cheated
on them right? So you're cheating on them you're having sex with
them after you've had sex with other people unprotected. You
know you're especially if you're not being diligent enough you
could Is this said with spider?
Yes. inadvertently be spreading a disease and that in and of
itself is
you know kind of a violation is is a violation of consent is
it not?
But um let [clears throat] not Well can I can I ask like >> yeah
go ahead.
It depends on what was said. There's ways I could see it not
being a violation of consent. Like if you set up an open relationship
intentionally you have a poly relationship you know the other
person sleeps with other people and you never ever have any sort
of agreement about what is required for protection on base on
the other person or what they're what they're doing. You never
say I need you to wear condoms when you have sex with other partners
cuz otherwise you need to wear a condom when you have sex with
me. That's like a normal one that people bring up. Okay. If you're
not saying something like that then you should assume that the
lack of like concern for safety they have with you is the same
they have with all of their other partners.
Him not
letting the other partners know
that he has STD or
Okay. Um
Oh does spider not get it?
Spider not get like the poss- like the argument he's trying to
make here?
That's goofy. Okay even in the best
that you have unprotected sex and you don't get to you don't
get a venereal disease or anything like that and you don't contract
it to somebody else you're still taking that risk. You're still
being negligent and hurtful like like really not even malicious
I don't negligent is probably a better word but
and you're potentially getting your giving your partner something
that they wouldn't have consented to otherwise like you know
how you spread This is not true Nora Blaze. Spider will understand
after this explanation 100%. He'll totally understand it. must
avoid catching an STD if you don't know that your partner's cheating
on you right? Unprotected you know? Like that's that's got to
feel violating. That feels like very violating thing.
Like it's not on the spectrum like the same as a violent forcible
assault right? But it is like with holding something that's kind
of vital in whether or not they would
um choose to consent
to that action that that that you know you know what I mean?
Like would you want would you want a woman cheating on you sleeping
around and then she caught something and then when she came back
to you you had sex you caught something because of that? >> Oh
okay okay okay now get it. He's for I'm with them. Okay, okay,
I got it. I got it. I got it. Okay, okay. Yeah.
That'd be Yeah, that'd be pretty bad. Called it. Called it. Called
it. Called
Called it. I called it. I know. The spider whisper, okay, very
easy. Very easy. I called it.
I'm not saying you're doing this intentionally, but like remember
the language of like how people talk about things. It's not even
just pretty bad, it's like really bad. >> Like it's It
could It could be really It's really bad.
Yeah. Don't Well, don't do it because it makes me happy. It's
just like No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no.
If this is true, allegedly. Like and based off your statement
right now, If this is true,
I'mma say this real quick.
I don't Jay has announced this alleged This is alleged. It's
not proven. Mhm. Take it with a grain of salt. That's
It's a It is a legend.
What are you talking about? Yeah. It's a legend. >> words
coming down? This guy's basically a philosopher. >> It's
a legend. Nothing is verified for
I'll say this I'll keep it in the back of pocket. Yeah. I'm still
going to be
Let me ask you something.
You talking about
This guy's just a racist. STD
I thought he was just joking. He's actually like a racist. It's
I I was totally wrong. I apologize to the Lunar Box Discord when
I gaslit you guys that Kweem wasn't racist at all and I knew
that, okay? He's I I'm I'm sorry. You know what? When I'm wrong,
I'm wrong.
Oh, yeah. I'm just going to wait until what Lunar Box says, right?
That's the other thing that's constantly misconstrued at least
from my end when people criticize me about talking about any
of this is they expect me They think the way I want people to
address their relationships with um problematic, controversial,
um uh downright deplorable people at times. They They want They
They They think that I want them to completely disassociate,
right? And not ever interact with them. But I'm telling I'm just
saying that you should
like truthfully what kind of things they are saying. Like Oh,
there's a I haven't looked at the chat.
I think Jay, this is the streamer here. I mean, Jay should apologize
since he's probably a hater account created and spreads fake
info with zero proof. I think it's weird that ex-partner of Lunar
Box is friends with all the stalkers. Like just be honest about
that perspective. Don't sweep up from and then just be honest
of well, despite that, I'm going to associate with them still.
And you can make whatever justifications you're your friend or
whatever. Like just Just be honest is what I'm saying.
Oh, it came out to be true, then like Even if the person's like
like a deplorable freak like Sorry, what did you say? I missed
that. Quick comment. >> By the talking about the alleged
stuff. He said alleged.
Alleged stuff. Alleged stuff, yeah.
Yeah. Like Even if the person's like like a deplorable freak
like that. Like I think just being honest and just saying like
I was friends with this person for quite a while or like I've
been a fan of this person for quite a while. Uh you can do the
I separate the art from the artist thing and this is why I watch
them. You could just be honest.
Is that how you guys defend being friends with Dan?
Uh kind of. I don't I don't expect Spider to like next Lunar
Box over this. Like I said, this isn't even tied to somebody's
identity. It could still technically just all be fake.
No, it's not. I don't That's not how I defend Dan at all. I don't
defend Dan. Oh, sure, sure,
Well, sorry, I didn't read the whole thing. Defend being friends
with Dan. Defend being friends with Dan.
>> I would never say any of this alleged. Yeah, alleged
true. Dan does this [__]
Oh, no, they're talking about how Spider's saying like Emery's
talking about separate the art from the artist, right? That's
That's like the thing. They're talking about separating the art
from the still the same thing.
All right. Is it like I don't defend this thing they did, but
I do talk to them in this other case. Yeah, it's not quite the
same, but it's basically saying that they I don't mind calling
out or criticizing the other things they do, but it doesn't mean
I'm going to forgo the benefits I get from talking to them or
something like that. Right? Is that not roughly what you would
say? Not that you talk to Dan a lot, but No, but I mean I It's
just a Yeah, it's just
There There isn't a case to cut them
You know?
I mean, I don't understand what Like I don't even understand
You could say that even though it's technically Why is it assumed
that it's like you're Oh, you're separating the art from the
artist in terms of friends if you still talk to someone who's
done a bad thing. Why is this Why is it assumed that any bad
thing requires cutting off? Like you have to build a case for
why I'm supposed to be cutting someone off, no. I think it more
means the whole like we love Dan stuff, probably. Like oh, you
know, I don't I don't I would not talk to Dan. I'd like, you
know, I just say what he did or not lie about what he did and
it's fine. Right? That's the argument.
But I It's like sort of hypothetical.
I don't think you have to cut anybody off in terms of being friends
privately.
I don't think that's the case. Unless you've given some reason
you wouldn't want to be around that person like as a Jesus Christ,
my mic arm's getting worse. Just If you've given like a reason
of why you don't want to be around people like that and you have
some principle you stated, then I don't see any reason why you'd
have to cut someone off
in a personal sense. I'm lucky now. >> If you Like yeah,
just be honest. If you If you feel that's worthy of like leaving
for, then yeah, obviously do that. Yeah.
The death allegation didn't make you dip by with this. And it's
It is hundred times worse. The death allegations
didn't make you dip from the DGG. community didn't I mean
have any personal relationship. I mean, it may sound like I don't
have a personal I'm not like a friendly terms with Destiny either.
I don't have like a personal relationship. You know, like like
personal You guys don't know like
like personal, you know, like friendship. Your impressions are
somewhat undercut by you consistently pulling away from the mic,
okay? How does Spider have a better audio setup than you? That's
kind of [__] up, isn't it? That's my machine. Yeah.
Okay. How many people been timed out from your chat for pointing
out that your microphone's not working?
There are recently.
I wonder why that is.
You know, I've seen I've seen zero people killed in Iranian protests
recently, too. Shocking that.
I ain't messing with you. Yeah, did you When you asked him why
he ducked with kids supreme or something?
Uh yeah. Was that bad? Was it good? No, I'm just making sure,
yeah. Yeah. And so so some defend Spider's one of the least like
Spider, I think, loves Destiny's content. He comments on Destiny's
content a lot. He's probably like the least one of the smaller
the least likely to defend Destiny in that Lunar Box community.
There's a lot of There's a lot of Destiny fans in that Lunar
Box community. I wouldn't count Spider as one of them. Yeah.
I I would straight up wouldn't count Spider as one of them.
Like in He I like listen.
That is like a Destiny fan community, but it's Spider's not one
of them. And if the person's like a total [__] uh
if I was making a verified allegation
I would just straightforwardly say it. Like I went
Spider's harmless. Spider's one of the only people who's actually
actually tried to ask somebody like, "Hey, why are you doxing
people?" There's like three people who even had the balls to
do that. Hey, why are you like doxing people? That seems kind
of [__] up.
Listen, there's like Slim Pickens, okay? Spider hung out in your
Discord too long to be on the plantation still. Maybe a little
bit.
He did post a lot of Destiny clips in the Discord, though. This
guy Why did you ask him And in general, he posts a lot of Destiny
clips. If If I'm friends with Purple Berry Gaming,
I want to know what's with Purple Berry Gaming that you want
to you need to know about.
Why you asked that question? I'm
He said uh streamers
uh remove the Donos from their streams all the time. It happens
all the time. Something like that on your Twitter,
Dude, you can tell Spider's not used to dealing with controversy.
He's giving like all of the worst possible excuses.
Guys, no, you Like you cut Donos out of streams all the time,
especially ones that don't risk TOS at all and are just personal
things. You You totally cut all of those out, guys. 100%. I Yeah,
people do that all the time.
What are you talking about?
Was that a video? It wasn't a video. Was it a video? I think
people said that was a video, no? It was the stream vod.
The stream vod. [clears throat and snorts] It's a little bit
of your friend. It's like the whole live stream is, yeah. That's
the
Can I ask I I could [clears throat] have sworn I seen people
saying like Lunar Box edited the video out, which is not The
or vod, which I thought
like it was like a video.
No, no, it's not a video. It's the vod itself. It's the vod itself?
Taking the vod the live stream vod and editing out a very specific
portion of it. Spider's like doing his best to sink Lunar Box
right now. He's making it sound like it's a way worse.
Oh, I thought it was a video. It was the vod? And then leaving
the rest.
Can you do You can. It's just
um Very noticeable.
It can be if done poorly.
Um I think it would be noticeable if somebody watched it live
stream pretty well or if it's badly edited enough.
Which apparently this one was, so >> you Do you still have
the same belief that people do it all the time?
Cuz I haven't seen anyone do it like at least on the box. Has
Lotterbox
on this on a vod before?
Yeah, he has actually. I don't I'm going to say this.
I don't think it's Lotterbox though. Maybe the editor, I'm guessing.
Maybe Why why would the editor do it? I assume like the editor
started us. Started I'm not sure. I don't know. I don't I don't
personally know. And then why did you say they do it all the
time? Everyone do that all the time. Well, cuz I thought you
meant I thought you were talking about like a video. >> now
that you know it's a vod and not Now that I know it's a vod,
why would they
uh remove this uh
All right. Don't you think it's suspicious? I'm not saying it's
evidence of anything. No one's saying it's
I'm just saying it's kind of suspicious.
I'll say
50/50. Fighters is fake, man. 50/50,
half and half. He's You have no idea what this guy thinks. It
could go either
Would that make you happy? What did you say? Would you be happy?
I don't even know. What the [__] was just said there?
Hold on.
Half and half. Would you be happy? Would that make you happy?
Okay.
I I didn't catch it. Oh my god, Doc Springer, you're so dumb.
I don't know how you live with yourself.
Jay, would you apologize if it turns out that it's alt account
or some snarker and not actual ex-partner of Well, I would apologize
if I were making a certain claim as if it were verifiably true.
You'll notice in my tweet, I don't suggest that Unfortunately
for the person making this tweet, this is the part that this
is an
This isn't As the science ex-partner was making out, you you're
assuming they're an ex-partner.
That is an assumption. I think like it's essentially it's an
it's an ex-partner or literally people trying to make it look
like that as much as possible for the sake of like like the the
idea of it being manufactured. If it were manufactured, like
you would have to go to such lengths to manufacture it such
like you look kind of for doing that in the first place. So,
I'm going to go ahead and say I assume Lotterbox and crew are
not that stupid.
And so I assume it's a real person and that's why it was edited
out. If you're like just trying to make it seem like a real person
after the fact cuz you want to do some sort of op, that would
be that would be so much more dumb than just actually cutting
this out of the
and when it when it's a real person and like sort of pointing
people at it. that the accusation is verifiably true. I say it's
an accusation.
I'm being honest. like the idea that somebody
the idea that you cut this out of the
if if somebody were like trying to make [__] up,
that's that's baffling. No no chance. That doesn't happen. It
is an accusation, is it not? >> Like somebody you don't
know, sorry. Kind of. But can I give you like like my perspective
and how would other people who don't really
like your topic of debate? I'm not saying you personally. Um
cuz you said it's like try to find a ex-partner, which implies
like he has some like evidence like you already there's like
proof to the the tweet, right? So, you admitted that Destiny
is a consent violator, but you >> Yes. Yes. Yes. Can I
post Can Can I not post a
a quote of him talking about the drama or not? That's what I'm
saying. You can, but it seems like you post You don't post negative
clips of
You only post negative clips of >> I I think he's posted
I think that is a negative clip of Destiny. Why Why is Kathy
getting on Spider?
It it literally is a negative clip. What That's all the people
you Destiny does Listen, who could stomach watching that guy
for long enough to find the clip where he says, "There's this
woke idea of consent out there. These people are putting out
this idea of this word consent."
Who else is going to watch?
Thank god for Spider in this case, okay? I would never been aware
of that very funny quote
if not for him. dislikes and Lotterbox dislikes. I've never seen
you once post like clips like, "Oh, look what Destiny did, which
is bad." Never seen you once do that. I wonder why. People want
negative Destiny clip. So, you want me to like post a anti-Destiny
clip, right? I'm not saying you You already did it. could do
that. I'm saying it's funny that you think this guy is a consent
violator, yet you post positive clips of him. He's saying it's
just a clip. I mean, if you call I mean, He's saying if you have
an actual grievance, if there's like a moral principle issue
that you have with the behavior
someone like Destiny, like
that you would think even just for even just for pragmatic clout
purposes, just like just frame it that way. Even if you just
wanted to talk about the drama, you have a lot of like you have
a lot of wiggle room to work with in terms of making content
tweets off. And it seems like your more interested in Destiny
reconning his Israel-Palestine takes and his audience not buying
it. What was the quote? We we watched this yesterday.
Oh, that was very funny. Like I I'm actually way more anti-Israel
than any of these any of these tanky [__] So goofy,
man. So goofy. >> on one particular person. Like if I were
if I were given something really juicy about Hasan that's actually
like I felt like was like morally depraved or and I felt like
was meaningful to criticize,
I would post it. I would have no issue with that. You know what
I mean? Like I would hyperfocus on that. Like other than something
like that.
Oh, there's like a new one from today? Hold on.
There's a new one from today?
Wait. Wait.
Another one?
No shot there's another one. Wait, hold on. I I haven't seen
it yet.
Do I want to try Do I want to try to Do I want to try to see
it? No, I I I saw enough that I can't spoil. I was going to try
to predict what he'd say. I was going to say something like he's
going to say how he's always disavowed in the West Bank or something
like this, okay? We'll see. And no amount of the behavior from
Israel, which they have engaged in over the past year, is going
to change my perspective on the beginning of the war. But all
these people have had that had that perspective literally since
like have had that perspective since day one. Sure, but I think
that's like the main con
Why would that Wait, why would that
If Destiny came out was like, "I'm going to advocate now. I think
you need to cut funding to Israel." Does he think people go,
"Wait.
What What are you saying? What about the beginning of the war
where you said it was okay." Do you think that's going to be
the resounding comments? Sorry, the resounding comments?
Most people are going to go, "Oh, that's good. Thank you. Thank
you."
Maybe you might get a small contingent of people who are like,
Too little, too late, man." And to some extent that's true, but
like also you're going to get a bunch of people who are like,
"Oh, thanks for standing on
mention. Like I think people think that you don't think it was
that bad and they think it's a lot worse. No, they think that
it was immoral from day one. That's what these people think.
Guaranteed. So, unless I take the same position that it was immoral
from day one, they would never find agreement with me. Cuz I've
already said this over and over again. I don't know Even after
the rubber thing, I've said over and over and over again, I don't
know why they're still at war. I don't know how many times they
have to go up and down the Gaza Strip looking for Hamas or they
keep I don't know where they are. You've It's
There's like a denouncement or disavowal
I don't know why they're still doing
It seems like you have made the whole GAZA STRIP 20 TIMES. I
SAID THIS A MILLION TIMES.
You said this a million times.
Dude, we should have I I was so lazy when he said he was clearing
out his YouTube channel. It would have taken me two days tops
to just write something that would have taken all of his existing
vods, the transcripts from
copied it over, right? Thrown it in a thing that's very much
like Filmod,
and then I would have just had that stuff. I should have done
it. I could have saved the ideas of the old video ideas of the
old videos so you could use it to look at old timestamps on vods.
All the old vods are on Odyssey, but the problem with the Odyssey
is you don't have the transcriptions.
So, you can't go and search like how many times did he talk about
Gaza?
I know some people have like a a save of all of this stuff, but
I I just don't. Oh, you do? Okay. Well, if you do, does the Filmod
still work for old vods? See if the Filmod does this live or
if it's doing it.
Is that Excel thing Oh, right. Well, no, the Excel thing won't
have specific lines. The Excel thing exists, but What if you
download all the transcripts by wand? I might grab those from
you cuz it would be it would be just useful to be able to search
like the old um
old vod things. Just cuz when he says stuff like this, like
bro, you talked about you said a million times that it was really
bad for Israel to be doing this in Gaza.
Come on. I
Who believes that? Nobody Ain't nobody believing that, bro. Come
on, man. But maybe the Filmod just still works right now. Things
that float on water naturally. Sorry, I'm trying to get through
this Filmod.
See here.
Oh, old vods are here still. It looks like. Some old vods are
here still and there's lots of old videos anyway. Okay, hold
on. 336 clips found searching Gaza on his YouTube channel.
Yeah, I'm not going to go over this right now. I It looks like
some of it still works or at least there's some vods that are
It's like looking at vods in some cases, but you can't look at
any of the old vods, so I'm lucky. Okay. All right. I sent you
who Destiny banned mid-clip.
It's a mid-clip ban?
What is this? There's nothing morally wrong with mowing down
Palestinians. They attacked first. This? Oh, I see.
This is the person he bans like mid-clip
So, would you say you were wrong in in initial support of how
Israel engaged in the war and you were just operating based on
what information was available.
I see, so you were wrong and just operating on what you knew
at the time. Wait. I've got to listen one more time >> amount
of the behavior from Israel, which they have engaged in over
the past few year, is going to change my perspective on the beginning
of the war. But all these people have had that um had that perspective
literally since um like have had that perspective for since day
one. Sure, but I think I think that's like the main contention.
Like I think people think that you don't think it was that bad,
and they think it's a lot worse. >> No, they think that
it was immoral from day one. That's what these people think,
guaranteed. So, unless I take the same position that it was immoral
from day one, they would never find agreement with me. Cuz I've
already said this over and over again. I don't know I even after
the Rafa
Is that really even like the the conversation you should have?
Oh, look, ogre boy just >> conflating things as well, is
cuz they I think it's immoral from day one because
it may be that a lot of these lefties
um envision
an abstract
a military action >> Yeah, exactly. >> from Israel
against Hamas in the wake of October 7th that would have been
moral.
But they know at October 7th, the action that Israel is planning
to take, or they feel like they know, on October 7th, the Israel
the action they're planning to take is not going to be moral,
and there's good reason for them to think that at that time,
and they turned out to be right. Uh-huh. That that's like the
real thing that's going on there, I think. Yeah, exactly. Like
you wouldn't even ask is
is it possibly is it possible that you're like morally justified
in doing some kind of response? Pretty much everybody says yes.
The question is, what do you think is likely to be the response
from Israel, and is that going to be okay? And some people lined
up on the yeah, let Israel respond, and and they're going to
be reasonable.
And even a year into the war, we still had people arguing that
like most moral army most moral army, most moral army. So, yeah,
exactly. And people were correct about the kind of response Israel
was about to engage in.
So. thing I've said over and over and over again. Um I don't
know why they're still at war. I don't know how many times they
have to go up and down the Gaza Strip looking for Hamas. Or they
keep I don't know where they are. YOU IT SEEMS LIKE YOU'VE INVADED
THE GAZA STRIP 20 TIMES. I SAID THIS A I SAW a Destiny clip just
that um
he says he doesn't look at like the what the streamer says anymore.
He just looks at what the audience says. So, maybe we should
do that. And no amount of the behavior from Israel, which they
have engaged in over the past few year, is going to change my
perspective on the beginning of the war. But all these people
have had that um had that perspective literally since um like
have had that perspective for since day one. Sure, but I think
I think that's like
the main contention. Like I think people think that you don't
think it was that bad. As you're resisting the oppressor, then
civilians I think civilians are okay to kill.
I don't think anybody said that. It was that bad.
Well, if you do think they would do that, then you don't actually
think it is a genocide because the definition of of it's about
intent and not strictly action. Dude, this is going to be rough
to read. Dude, it's also see supporting Israel is binary, like
you either do or you don't when there's a lot of in
I mean, you can support Israel as much as you like, and in some
sense that is advocating for further tax dollars
As long as you're like, oh, we should totally defund Israel and
wait until they fix their behavior to to fund them any further,
then yeah, you could be like, but I still think Israelis are
good people. You can go ahead. That's fine. I think they think
it's a lot worse. >> No, they think that it was immoral
from day one. That's what these people think, guaranteed. So,
unless I take the same position that it was immoral from day
one, they would never Destiny, so you were wrong and just operating
on what you knew at the time. Dude. find agreement with me. Cuz
I've already said Uh, I thought this is going to be
People in the comments of the video didn't even watch the full
video before commenting, going on a rant, giving your whole perspective
on IP to give a hook for the 10-minute ads to start the video.
What is his position going to be? I I support this. Yeah, give
it lay out lay out your lay out lay out your entire position
on Israel-Palestine right now, like how you feel about it.
>> I'd love to see that. I've already said this over and
over again. I don't know I even after the Rafa thing, I've said
over and over and over again. Um Like that one Reddit comment
about a police officer shooting the knife out of someone's hand.
Oh, everybody's just laughing about special forces. No, but
Everybody just engaged with the most argument around this. know
why they're still at war. I don't know how many times they have
to go up and down the Gaza Strip looking for Hamas. Or they keep
I don't know where they are. YOU IT SEEMS LIKE YOU'VE INVADED
THE GAZA STRIP 20 TIMES. I SAID THIS A MILLION TIMES. And no
amount of
Okay, the Rafa thing. Oh, true. True, the Rafa thing.
>> What did they do in Rafa, Destiny? What did they do
in Rafa?
Say what it was. Say the whole thing.
Incredible stuff. Okay.